for next week unless your subcommittee
decides to meet
take the week off go party
and i'm planning
an exec for the remaining bills
on march 7th which is the monday before
election day
and the monday before the deadline which
is
thursday the 10th so
all the bills that are in subcommittee
need to be out and ready to go that day
so
get your work done that's it
i don't know how many
um senate bills or second committee
bills will be getting
until
the end of the week
yeah
monday is the state house is closed for
the holiday
that's the
president's day
no no next week is off
not not that i know of the um
not unless we don't get very far on
these two days and they decide at the
spur of the moment to have one but
i haven't heard anything certainly
nothing official
no but i would lay money it's going to
be
the week after the 10th
i think we'll be on
we have march here
it being one o'clock welcome to edna and
i'm opening the public hearing on house
bill 1135 and call the sponsor
representative fellows
thank you madam chair i'm representative
sally fellowes from holderness and i'm
here to introduce hb
requiring an audit of education freedom
accounts
for 30 years i worked at the department
of education i was involved with audits
of both federal and state funding
programs
and
this included an lba
performance audit of adequacy aid of
school districts right after the state
increased
funding and changed the allocation
formula in response to the claremont
lawsuit
so why did i file this bill
it warrants lba
the program warrants lba review because
it is unlike any previous state school
aid program
and i've just identified five five ways
that that it's different and not that
those are the only way but just to give
you a a general overview for those that
are not
really familiar with the program
the state department of education is not
managing this program it is contracted
out to a private entity the contractor
keeps 10 percent of each student's
allocation
and parents can utilize ninety percent
the more students that sign up the more
money the contractor will make
school districts expend a hundred
percent of their adequacy aid in the
year they receive it
with efas education freedom accounts
the full
allocation goes to the contractor
in payments for payments throughout the
year
but parents need not expend their share
each year
they can delay spending any of
the their allocation for years and let
it accumulate in their account
so it's important to understand how the
cash will be managed by the contractor
will the contractor keep it in banks
stock
bitcoin
the payouts for this program
range between approximately four hundred
four thousand and eight thousand dollars
per student each year
this is a significant amount of money
and can be an enticement for fraudulent
claims
does nhdoe or the contractor have
sufficient safeguards in place to
prevent fraud
i think it's it will be very important
and also very difficult to verify that
all recipients are and continue to be
new hampshire residents
while some of the efa efa students will
be attending private schools many will
not
parents are required to provide annual
test results
of a test of their
choosing they can
select from a list that has several
options
or a statement that a teacher has
reviewed a student portfolio
but there are no benchmarks or minimum
report performance requirements for
continued funding
so how will the contractor verify that
students are actually being educated
maybe the most important reason
for this audit is that we have no idea
how much this program will cost going
forward
we don't even have a good idea of who is
participating in the program
nhdoe the
state department of education estimated
before the
this legislation was passed that 50
students would participate less than 50
students would participate in the first
year
but as of last new november enrollment
was over 1600 and i believe that there
have been several hundred more students
that have enrolled since then
to understand future costs we need to
understand who is participating
that's why i included
in the bill
an analysis of the demographic data of
the students that are participating in
the program
so we need this performance audit to
ensure that state funds are being
appropriately managed because because
we're talking about a potential we're
talking about eight million dollars
already for this current year and it
could well be a lot more in the future
so um i'll answer any questions you have
i am chris shea who is the deputy lba
the deputy legislative budget assistant
is also here and he can
answer questions for you about the
particulars of how a performance audit
functions but if you have any questions
for me i'm happy to try to answer them
thank you representative lackas has a
question thank you um
as i recall from the original bill
there was created as part of it a
legislative oversight committee
which is supposed to monitor what's
going on with the program is that
you know how would that interact with
this plus i think there may have been an
auditing requirement
in the original uh bill as well although
i don't know the details are you
familiar with that
so the original bill did not have any
requirement for an lba audit i don't
think i don't think ever
does a bill
you know yeah i didn't say lba so well
this is an lba audit
so
it can cover the things that are
addressed in this bill and and
potentially other things
there the bill does specify that the
report goes to i think it says finance
it goes to that oversight committee that
you're talking about department of
education but
but audits are
also
after they're reviewed well i'll let
um okay thank you chris shea
just
tell you what happens with the audits
i will mention that edna
normal always gets performance audits
and it is part of our duty to
look at them and see if they need
further action by the legislature
sometimes they do sometimes they don't
we haven't done very many in the last
few years kovan being one reason
but we are also
in the people that read and
review if not approved performance
audits representative had a question no
okay representative scitec
hi hi representative fellows i'm
interested in your point four and your
uh handout and you say that many will
attend private schools many will not
where are they where are those people
are they home schools is that what that
means
so that that's one of the questions so
if you look at if you turn your page
over
you'll see
this report so this is this is the first
page of a report that was produced in
november about the program um there are
a couple more pages that i didn't bring
the the other the pages that i did not
include are tells you exactly what town
the students live in
but this is a summary and if you look at
the block that's right here
this this tells you that
they
the department of education knows where
43 of those students
came from and from came from i mean did
they come from
public schools or did they
were they ever in public schools that's
what it tells you
so
it tells us this tells us that 57
percent of the students
that
signed up at the beginning of the 1600
that 70 percent of them have never been
enrolled in public schools in new
hampshire
so who so where are they they could be
home school students
they could be private school students
they could be a few of them can be
kindergartners but not very many because
there's a block down here that tells you
how many students from each grade
so that's one of the one of the issues
did people
you know just think of what could be
happening did people move from out of
state in new ham into new hampshire
so they could utilize this program
where they're people who
you know in terms of potential fraud
there are plenty of people who own
second homes in new hampshire did they
change their residency to say we'll call
this our regular home so we can
get you know
you know four six eight thousand dollars
a year to send our kid to a private
school who's
maybe they're already going to that
private school so that's that's why we
don't really know
thank you is that a follow-up yeah
we're getting dangerously close to the
weeds so i'll stop here thank you
other questions for representative
fellows
okay not seeing any thank you
um
what was oh there was
you'll need a pink card representing
fellows
i'm sure it'll come to you at some point
usually a bit
are there people who would like to hear
from the lba for summary of performance
audits yes okay
mr shea we'd be delighted to hear from
you
uh thank you good afternoon for the
record my name is chris shea i'm the
deputy legislative budget assistant um
i've worked for the lba for since 1996
the first 10 years of working with the
lba i was working in performance audits
since then i've come over to the budget
side and have worked on the budget and
financial issues as it relates to
legislation and other issues within the
branch
so today i was asked to come and just
speak with you at a high level as to
what a performance audit is and how it
kind of comes to be
performance audits are
the the topic matter is controlled or
com is provided by the legislative
performance audit oversight committee
that's a 10 person committee it's five
house members and five senators
they will come up with a topic
discuss it with our audit group
our audit group will take that topic
and they will scope it and scope it just
basically means they're going to take a
look at what information might be out
there related to the area that the
committee would like to have audited and
they come back with a report to the
legislative performance audit committee
to indicate what they believe an audit
could accomplish for that particular
topic area if the committee agrees with
you know what the scope statement is or
or what the question is
then they move forward if they need to
refine it then our auditors would work
with them and refine the question to
make sure they can get at a
good audit essentially once the
legislative performance audit site
committee agrees on the question they
need to present it to the fiscal
committee for approval
so fiscal committee will approve the
topic
and once that's approved our auditors
will go out and conduct the audit
audits can take
several months to half a year
depending on the size and scope of a
performance audit
sometimes they might be you know review
a division for efficiency and
effectiveness which is typically the
the words that we associate with a
performance audit
we can also do compliance as well
our auditors follow
government auditing standards
you may have heard if you're familiar
with auditing at all you may have heard
the term yellow book which is the
book put out that they follow
once the auditors finish their report
they bring it back to the fiscal
committee who will accept the report and
it will be distributed and as the chair
indicated many times performance audit
reports will come back before the edna
committee in the house
with a presentation from our audit staff
to just let you know what they had done
and what their conclusions were as a
result of the audit
so that's a kind of a high level
um indication of what occurs with the
audit there's recommendations it's very
um
involved with the agencies you know
there's a lot of interviews um there may
be surveys there will be data reviews
um
so it's
collaborative with the agency but we do
control the audit
um
and just if if i can take a step back
representative lucas had a question
about how our auditors might
interact or associate with a the
advisory commission that's in the bill
uh the original bill that set up the
efas
they would they would have um interviews
and and and probably consult with them
to see what that commission has done and
are they meeting what the um
the function or charge was for that
group
at this point um
this is a fairly new program um
our auditors would probably look at more
of a compliance aspect at this point you
know did the program get implemented as
the law had indicated and probably less
on efficiency and effectiveness just
because there wouldn't be a lot of data
related to that at this time
so happy to try to field any questions
that people might have
representative shut and then psychic
thank you madam chair
good afternoon mr shea thank you for
coming to edna
hopefully we'll get to see you again
you kind of
quickly glanced over the topic that the
commission or committee that
works with you
comes up with a topic
how does that work how do they get
topics
the legislative performance audit and
oversight committee
may come in the members may come in with
their own ideas
you as members of the house and senate
could also come and present an idea to
the committee
um our auditors may come forward with
suggestions if directed by the chair of
that committee
um
you know it
there's a variety of ways that they can
come forward and what the committee
would do is debate the topics and and
rank as to what they feel are the most
important ideas that they'd want to have
audited typically they give our audit
shop
two three four topics to kind of have in
the queue
and then when we come back and meet with
them
you know they might adjust the order of
those audits that they the priority
might change or maybe something new has
has come up in discussions through
committee's work or uh you know through
the press that's maybe there's a topic
matter like we really need to look at
this agency because there's a lot of
things going on
um so so there's some fluidity to it but
our auditors will start an audit and
work it through to the end unless
directed to stop it um and that's not
that doesn't happen very often
that's a more of a
representative
thank you mr shea i don't know why i
want to say carlin for some reason
representative excuse me mr shea have
you looked at the uh
representative fellow's list of uh her
five uh
areas of interest or
i i hadn't before this moment no i she
handed it to me i didn't look at it i
was listening to when she read it well
if you had my question would have been
are they fit top would they be addressed
by an lba audit
if i had i would have answered they may
or may not be depending on if the
information is available thanks so at
this point as i stated that um our
auditors would scope
the topic matter
um you know in the bill itself there's
um eight seven points that are being
asked to be addressed we may not be able
to address all of those in an audit at
this point because there just may not be
information i think what reps and
fellows is uh indicated in her five
points or some some potential risk areas
our auditors might come back and
indicate there may be there may be a
need for more controls or discussion for
controls in certain areas but i'm not
sure at this point they'd have a lot of
data to say that it's occurring or not
occurring
thank you representative leckus
thank you um
this is kind of a a process question i
don't know if you'd be better or the
chair would be better to answer it
and you mentioned that you get your
the audits that you do from um the audit
committee and then finance reviews them
um so i guess the question is if we were
to pass this bill what would it really
do
so it's just a hint to the audit
committee or
uh so if you pass this bill it would be
in legislation that we would do this
audit okay so that
um at this point there's not a time
associated with it so i would
suggest that our auditors would complete
audits that are in the queue at the
moment and put this
you know in the list of audits to
complete but it wouldn't be up for
discussion necessarily because the full
body has passed it
um so it it removes the
the legislative performance audit
oversight's ability to set the topics
though it does ask the
audit group to come back and present the
scope to them so that they can at least
review whatever
direction we might be headed with an
audit okay thank you
to make sure that we cover the points
that are maybe contained in the bill
okay are there any other questions
representative goalie
thank you madam chair
i've now you said that i just was
looking at the bottom the effective date
shall take effect july 1st 2022.
so
anything that's in the queue as of that
date forward you would
put it in from there
correct yes i so
this bill would take effect then it
doesn't say that the audit needs to take
happen at that point so i would suggest
and
having not talked to the director of
audits about this but i would suggest
that they would probably add it to the
queue that the performance audit
oversight has already given them a
couple of topics to work on they would
add this this to it the other thing is
they probably wouldn't want to engage in
this
uh before at least the full year has has
gone by
so it probably wouldn't be before the
fall before they would even consider the
topic to give it a full year that's
where i was going with that so it'd be
another full year in the uh so you'd
have the first
you'd have since last
fall through this upcoming fall
potentially to look at so one
one year 12 months
we typically like to look at it in in
fiscal years
but we it doesn't necessarily have to be
that way we would give a time frame for
what we were looking at
thank you
representative allegra
thank you so i uh
that was a good description of procedure
but i'm still not clear on what a
performance audit is
is it just a uh
a financial and procedural audit or is
it actually auditing
uh the performance that the institution
is intended to uh to undertake
it would be more of the latter so the
performance audit typically looks at
efficiency and effectiveness of a
program or a
process
we would look to make sure that statutes
best practices things like that are
being followed and have been implemented
we would make suggestions on how to
maybe make improvements around that
we would include
maybe budgetary numbers but they
wouldn't be audited financials and we
have a finance side that does the
financials for
state agencies follow-up
so there are performance audience
currently being performed for the public
school system is that the case and
how are they measuring up are they
meeting performance standards
so i'm sorry repeat that first part i i
assume there are performance uh audits
uh taking place with public schools
and if so
are they measuring up to performance
standards
um
just some background information yeah so
i
we we audit state agencies so we
wouldn't necessarily go into the public
schools
if they are having audits typically
their financial audits they may have
other types of reviews but we're
typically auditing state agencies and
the implementation of programs that
they're charged with
we have the ability to audit um
entities that receive state funds
but we're limited in the in the number
of those that we can do in a five-year
period and it's five so we don't
typically go outside of the state
agencies because we can
we have more than enough work with the
audits
group that we have trying to get those
done
so this bill i'm sorry one more
follow-up so this bill would actually
require
an additional or higher standard
than what the public schools are
undergoing is that the case if they're
not undergoing performance standards
like this um i can't speak to public
schools and and what they might be
undergoing it's not an area that i'm
well educated in i guess and or have a
good handle on
what i would say is that what we would
be doing is going into
the department of education and
determining how they've implemented this
program in determining whether it was
done as the law directed
were there some things that maybe
didn't happen or could be happening that
would make it better and we would
comment on that the agency would have an
opportunity to provide a response to
that and then the report would be issued
to the fiscal committee and then
disseminated to the members
thank you
if anyone is not familiar with
performance audits there's a nice stack
of of them
on my desk in outside room 306 you're
more than welcome to rummage through and
and pick some out there's also financial
audits there too which are
which are which are totally different
and everything can be found on our
website as well so if you're interested
in an audit or see if an agency's had
any financial and or performance audit
conducted you would find it on our
website
representative o'brien
thank you madam sheriff
i thank representative allegro because
it got me thinking i mean the big
difference here from what i understand
this is going to make sure on a vulture
type of program where the individual the
money is going to go to the individual
student
whereas let's say in the example of
municipality
debt is figured by a municipal budget
superseded by their particular governing
board of that particular community uh
watching so there's a great difference
in other words there's nobody watching
the hen house and this is probably
what's the nexus of this
particular uh asking you to look at this
particular audit correct
this would just be another look at the
hen house i think that in the bill
itself there was a an advisory
commission set up to review
um one issue report once a year in
review of the program but i think what
represent fellows has indicated in her
five points is that there there may be
some
potential for things to happen if we
don't keep an eye on it in terms of
fraud or some other
issues with the money but we can't say
that at this time and and without having
conducted an audit but again an audit at
this point would be
limited to you know a period of of a
year or less and we probably would be
limited to really looking at um
compliance you know was the program set
up the way the legislature intended did
the department of education
do the pieces that they were required to
do
and is there elements of it that are
related to the scholarship organization
that's running the program or they have
they done what they should do as it
relates to the law but it may not
necessarily be an audit of the detail
behind that at this point just because
of timing but again that would be up to
our auditors to assess when they get
into it i would say this is
intended to be more an audit of the
scholarship organization than of
anything else
would that be a correct assumption of
how it operates and what and what it
produces
i mean you're the only one who could
speak is too intense yeah so i think the
part that's
that's so different about this program
compared to
other education funding
strategies that we've had is that it's
being done by a contractor
so you don't have the same kind of you
know when i was at the department of
education
multiple people
could see what everyone else was doing
and and we had a pretty good sense of
like what kind of controls that we had
but this is different
and so we want to make sure we're not
the oba doesn't look for fraud what
they're looking for is procedures
that will prevent that from happening
and so that's what thank you i think i
think that's that's the answer to my
question
are there other questions for mr shea
i don't see any thank you for for uh
coming to talk to us well you're welcome
and if anybody you know thinks of
anything after this meeting and would
like to contact me at my office feel
free to do so
okay
is there any other member of the public
who would like to testify
all right not seeing any i will close
the public hearing
on house bill 1135
okay
and we have 20 minutes before our
next hearing
and if someone if we want to go into
executive session
is that agreeable
okay
representative
goalie i think you had a comment on a
motion on house bill 1287 sleep
awareness month
thank you madam chair
i will move inexpedient to legislate
is there a second second
okay representative goalie moves in
expedient to legislate
and represent grodus seconds it
would you care to speak to your motion
yes
this committee has taken a stance as to
putting
naming months days weeks into statute
i i don't think
a purpose is served by putting it in one
time and then having it in there
perpetually without
having an organization coming forward
and
fighting for their cause on an annual
basis
and i think it's
more effective having those groups
go to the governor
for a proclamation
on a yearly basis for what they truly
feel is worthy of being observed
so for that reason i move in expedient
to legislate thank you representative
perrotta
representative goalie
succinctly and thoroughly explained the
position
excellent is there anyone else who
wishes to speak on the motion
okay i don't see anybody so the motion
is inexpensive to legislate on house
bill 1287
and the clerk can call the roll
yes thank you
the clerk votes yes representative
yakubovic
yes
excuse me representative lekkis
representative allegro yes
representative bailey
yes representative lanzarra yes
representative goalie
yes representative schuett
yes
representative judy we miss you
representative marsh yes
representative fellows yes
representative fontenot yes
representative grota yes representative
o'brien
yes
and the chair
fifteen to zero fifteen to zero all
right the motion passes fifteen to zero
is there any objection to consent
seeing none we'll put it on consent
does anyone else have a motion on any
other bill
yes representative schuett i have an
amendment
to house bill 1330 if you think we have
time no
no 1330 is going to be more contentious
we don't have a full house i only want
to do bills that are going to go on
consent
all right um
let me um
how about house bill 1446
uh the governing board of recreational
therapists and uh respiratory care
practitioners
okay i'll i'll second that
that's ought to pass
ought to pass yes okay
this is house bill 1446 the governoring
board of recreational therapists and
uh respiratory respiratory therapists
yes it's uh this this again was um i'm
hoping you recognize me to speak to my
motion please speak to your motion
this again was making these two builds
two boards
advisory only
and i did go through
what the executive director of oplc had
originally drafted
and included my favorite phrase in
consultation with the advisory board
at all aspects
that
would involve
expertise from the board members
and that leaves her to just take care of
the administrative duties
i think if you look through the bill you
will see
those that phrase added where i felt it
was necessary
madam chair was a second yes i seconded
okay i think this this was a bill that
actually came out of two separate bills
that we started into the process and
then discovered they were in the same
statute so we
saved the committee the trouble and
combined them before it got to us
it's
it is just one of my favorite terms
housekeeping it does make it an advisory
board but these two boards are
relatively small and don't have issues
with this
so i think it's
it is acceptable to them and and uh
initiated by the oplc
representative o'brien you have a
question
thank you madam chair uh would the chair
be so kind
uh to explain to you maybe i missed it
but when we heard testimony from
director courtney uh
if the question was brought up to her
that this may be a need of a transition
amendment
into this do i have that correct
i don't recall it specifically but
representative schuett i think has a
better answer than i would
thank you
that was a different bill we we did
work on several different boards i did
talk to
the executive director about this bill
and she felt that these two were pretty
simple
and therefore could go forward with the
i believe it's 60-day
transition period
the assumption would be exist
the assumption would be that the
director would appoint to the advisory
board the people who are on the current
regulatory board
and that would simplify the transition
you don't have also don't have to worry
about licenses
being invalid because it's the same
organization yep
think about scitec actually that would
apply to the other bills too
in that the
executive director can make those
appointments
but a couple the difference was with the
uh
assessors board because that moved from
dra to oplc but go on representative
okay um first uh
if a board has
i had mentioned this i called it voting
with their feet if a board can't if
these boards that can't get quorums as
far as i'm concerned they shouldn't even
be licensed at all leave that my
my petulance aside for a moment and
let's try to do it right if we're going
to do this
and we were talking with an unnamed
representative over there
that
i think we have not looked at this
carefully enough the whole situation i
don't like the word advisory
i mean who has the last call
i think the answer to this
quorum issue should have been handled
this way and the horse has sort of left
the barn i think it should be
we should allow for alternates
uh we should allow for virtual meetings
and i don't like it being advisory i
think if it's if it's to be done right
it shouldn't be in consultation they the
board should have the last word
and so i'll go along with this but i
was
i wish i had thought of this when the
first issue when it first surfaced
because i think that would be the better
way to handle it and i don't know how
others may feel
i'd be happy to simply repeal the
requirement to license these people but
i don't think that would go very far
representative goalie
thank you madam chair and i just want to
let uh represent scitec know that one of
those solutions is headed our way i
believe and that is to allow them to
meet virtually so we will have that
option to give them hopefully
sometime in the future
yes and i as i recall the
it wasn't so much that the board wasn't
meeting it's just that they kept getting
swamped by administrative tasks
which
if they have the full authority to do
all that then
they also got the responsibility in
there
they didn't have they had trouble
meeting those representatives psychic
and then allegra that's good to hear i'm
glad but they're still holes and i just
don't like the word advisory
representative yeah uh representative
scitec actually beat me to the punch i
just wanted to express that his
sentiment he's not the only one with
those sentiments so thank you
is there
any other comments representative
schuett
thank you madam chair i will just point
out that
the only practitioner of these two
practices i guess i'll say
who was present did speak in favor of
this idea so
that's good to know any
other comments questions
all right
seeing none the motion is ought to pass
on house bill 1446
and the clerk can call the roll
the clerk votes yes
representative yakubovic
yes representative alecus yes
representative allegro yes
representative bailey
yes representative alonzara yes
representative goalie
yes representative schuett
yes representative judy we miss you
representative
of marsh yes representative fellows yes
representative fontenot yes
representative grota yes representative
o'brien
yes the chair
yes
i guess we have 15-0 again all right the
motion passes 15-0 is there any
objection to consent
seeing none
i will
which is
we already killed that
yeah
that was so obvious that we killed it
immediately
i have a motion madam chair
uh
yes versus
itl on house bill 1443
which is the declaring the first monday
of march just covered 19 victims and
survival day
survival memorial day
okay represent representative lekkis
seconds what number was that bill
do you care to speak to your motion
yes
i think this bill falls in line with the
other bills that we've had commemorating
different events
and this is a um an event that i think
is worthy of recognition but it could be
done in a different way more productive
map way thank you okay representative
uh no further comments she covered it
does anyone wish to speak about house
bill 1443
covert remembrance day
mo the the motion is itl
okay
seeing no other comments
the motion is an experience to legislate
on house bill 1443
and the clerk can call the role the
clerk versus yes representative
yakubovic yes representative alekas yes
representative allegro yes
representative bailey yes representative
zara yes representative goalie yes
representative should yes
representative judy we miss you
representative um marsh
no
representative fellows
yes representative fontenot yes
representative grota yes representative
o'brien
yes the chair
yes
1.
do you object to consent no okay
if there's no other objection we'll put
this on consent the mo the motion passes
14 to 1.
all right
okay
i think that
that may be all we can do today but uh
what yes representative i don't have a
motion but i'd like to address
representative fellows and i think i'm
in very much in favor of the audit
but it sounds like they want to do it on
a fiscal year basis they'd like to have
a year behind them uh so this your bill
i think
i'm in favor of the the idea but it may
be premature
so
by the time they get to it like around
october it would be a whole fiscal year
and it would be a whole year of the
program
okay we're out of executive session
we'll
get a couple of minutes before the next
hearing
it having reached
1 45 i'm opening the hearing on house
bill 1510 and i call representative
infantine
i always tell everyone the word of the
last two years should be you're on mute
i represent
manchester ward six
and i'm here to introduce
house bill 1510 the prime sponsor
representative attitude was unable to
make it here today so i agreed
when representative addison contacted me
you know in september and asked me if i
would agree to sponsor the bill this is
normally something i wouldn't really be
involved with
but when you explain to me some of the
time delays that occur in the state
process
that's when i agreed to
come on board
we do have issues with how the state
hires folks
i know that specifically because in the
last two months since i agreed to
co-sponsor this bill
the lead electrician
head inspector has left
the electrician's board and gone to the
dra
an employee of 25 years from the
insurance department has now left and
gone to
fish and game
so it seems like we have a process which
allows our good employees within the
state to move into other positions but
we seem to have a hard time hiring
individuals and the circumstance seems
to be
once you start once you apply
other people who are really looking if
you all know if you're looking for a job
you look for multiple jobs you're going
to look to see what is out there what
kind of offers you get
and if if you're really looking for a
job because you've made a mental
decision to leave the job you're in
and you find a job possibly with a state
that you think appeals to you but it
takes three or four months to get hired
more often than not the state goes
through that process point i'm told i
don't work within the state so i don't
know so this is anecdotal
that by the time they make a decision 90
120 days later the candidates are gone
they've gone somewhere else so are we
doing ourselves a favor
uh by taking so long
now madam chairman woman i was in the
same meeting with you where we were told
this is not the kind of the year to have
a lot of study committees and i and i
get that
um
so i respect the position we're in um
with the pandemic and people not wanting
to meet and not being able to get
senators to agree to study committees
but
and we've all been here long enough to
know that certain study committees
have an outward agenda
we know the person submitting it
sometimes wants to know
already knows what they want out of it
so it can be used for future possible
legislations this is about as innocuous
as possible it's about as clean as i can
see there's no agenda no one's looking
for anything
but maybe we can do a better job hiring
folks by shorting the process
thank you madam chairwoman thank you
representative are there questions from
the committee representative laccas
thank you um
do you know if the uh
the long time involved in the hiring
process is related to statute that we
need to change or is it something the
departments could just change fix on
their own
i'm sorry with all due respect i don't
know the answer to that question thank
you maybe someone behind me will have a
better ability to answer that
president
thank you madam chair
um do you know how many openings we have
in our state agencies at this time
i figured this question was going to
come up and i would be careful how i
answer it
there are
a significant amount of
of job openings some feel that's okay
because we had too many openings and our
budget may be a little too heavy so it's
okay to have some of those openings but
i can tell you alone i'm aware of issues
with
getting
permits
through the des for new residential
subdivisions and apartment buildings
because they just don't have the staff i
know the deep department of
transportation is down a number of
engineers
and they're not to be able to get as
much work out as they have in the past
and let alone we all know the story
about uh plowed
truck drivers in the state of new
hampshire so i don't have the exact
number but just information from
individual departments where they're
just down at least one or two people
so the lack of these employees lack of
our inability to fill these positions
is
having an effect on the performance of
the agencies
that is my understanding and again this
is just a study committee there's no
indictment of any system or procedure
that we're utilizing but to review it
and to see if we can make it better
thank you
other questions
all right thank you very much
i call representative kaplan
dude thank you madam chair and good
afternoon members of the edna comm uh
committee
for the record my name is representative
tony kaplan and i represent merrimack
six that's the towns of henneker and
bradford
and i'm here to speak on behalf of house
bill 1510 a bill that would establish a
study committee
to help us fill various openings of
state agencies in new hampshire
typically
a study committee will include
consideration of the complexity of the
application
process for job openings estate agencies
the hiring and onboarding process and
the
the turnaround time from the initial
application to the start date and see if
these various aspects of the hiring
process impact the state's ability to
fill vacant job positions
in a job market as competitive as the
one we're in today the hiring process
can be the difference between
filling a position
and losing qualified applicants
several mid-level managers at various
state agencies communicated to the prime
sponsor representative adjutant that the
archaic nature of the application
process and
onboarding process made it difficult to
get qualified people on the door
as one person put it
between how long it takes to apply and
how long it takes to onboard someone by
the time we call them for a start date
they've taken a new position somewhere
else
and the state finds itself down
qualified applicants that could have
helped out
delivering vital services to our
constituents
in this economy with people living
paycheck to paycheck they often don't
have time to wait
weeks and weeks for an employer to get
back to them and it's causing us to lose
qualified applicants
i firmly believe we ought to study
uh this problem uh to see if we can
relieve state agencies and uh get the
vital services that our constituents
need
uh in a timely fashion so i urge you to
support this bipartisan bill
and thank you i'll take questions if you
have any
thank you representative has a question
this is not a facetious question i'm
just wondering why is it that state
agencies
do they not have the flexibility to
change their hiring process to become
more competitive
representative i think that's one thing
that the study committee would be
looking at okay yeah i mean i think as
the previous person testified i don't
really know the answer to that but that
would be the purpose of the committee to
get to the bottom of what is impact
thank you
anyone else
thank you representative kaplan thank
you representative sullivan
thank you madam chair
thank you to the committee for hearing
my testimony
i think any time um
the chair of the labor committee and the
ranking member of the labor committee
can testify in the same bill
both in support um
it
emphasizes the fact that we are indeed
looking at a a bipartisan issue here
um i don't think there's anything
partisan about
the state needing to hire
qualified quality individuals
and get them on board as quickly as
possible
it seems like that's just something that
benefits the state and all the
departments
in general
i myself don't know why there's a delay
like this i know it's not unique to new
hampshire
one of our representative colleagues
son
just got hired into one of the
departments in new jersey and i think
it's taken six months for him to
actually get on board
so it happens in other states as well
but i'd like to see new hampshire be
better than other states and if there
are ways that we can streamline the
uh the process get people on board
quicker and get the best candidates
before they go somewhere else
i think that's a good thing and i don't
think we know the answer to exactly why
this is an issue
so this study committee can very much
provide answers to that
whether we need
new legislation or not is unknown it may
be that
the departments can simply get some
some guidance from the study committee
as to how to go about
streamlining their hiring process
so with that i won't repeat what's been
said earlier thank you
thank you will you take questions yes
representative fellows
thank you madam chair um i'm not trying
to put you on the spot but you said you
were on the labor committee so i thought
maybe you'd have some insight in this
direction
would you agree
that
the process for a private company to
hire an individual
is fundamentally different from
a
government entity which could be you
know a school district or town or the
state
because
the private agency has the private
company has the ability to just like say
i want somebody right away so i'm going
to just take the first person who you
know is well qualified that comes
through the door
but this
the government entity
has to deal with all kinds of issues
like
fairness in terms of um that everybody
gets a chance to apply for that job
and concerns about
that a person doesn't get the job just
because you know their friend works in
that department and they hear about it
so it's only open in the you know so if
you get in quick you can get hired in a
week
but and your question representative
fellow yeah about the difference do you
know i haven't heard anybody say that
they understand that this
public
entity has
different responsibilities in terms of
hiring
i think that's probably true to some
extent
which i think is why we need the study
committee to
streamline our process as much as
possible so that we can
speed it up while still getting quality
candidates doing background checks and
everything that's needed for a
particular position
but um
trying to compete with the private
sector that's able to move quickly i
think you're right but um
we need to do better
any other questions from the committee
okay seeing none thank you
representative
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on house bill 1510
do we have anybody from the division of
personnel here
it doesn't look like it
oh excuse me
would you care to step up introduce
yourself and perhaps answer some
questions obviously the division of
personnel is deeply involved in the
hiring process
good afternoon my name is carolyn
russell i'm senior operational analyst
with the department of administrative
services i've been embedded in the
division of personnel for two and a half
years working with them on their
modernization efforts and efforts to
improve their processes and programs
am i not close enough
close to the mic very close to the mic
do you want me to reintroduce myself
carol and russell i'm a senior
operational analyst with the department
of administrative services and i've been
embedded within the division of
personnel for two and a half years
working with them on their modernization
efforts and streamlining of their
processes and procedures
thank you do you have anything to say
about this study committee or the state
agency hiring process that will
enlighten us it is an issue that the
department of the division of personnel
is working on
actively
because we recognize the need for
streamlined processes for recruitment
and hiring
we have been training
state
hr professionals on procedures and
hiring managers on procedures for hiring
to try and facilitate and expedite those
procedures
one of the challenges we have in the
state is
is the time that folks have available
because of the staffing issues we
currently have 19 vacancy rate and we
are competing in the labor market where
it is necessary to act quickly excuse me
you said 19
yes we currently have a vacancy rate of
19 statewide
matter of fact i calculated that this
morning thank you
questions representative valackas
i i think my quest thank you i think my
questions have just been answered the 90
is across all departments the whole
state
across statewide for classified
full-time employees
okay thank you
representative
thank you madam chair
taking the role of representative
schmidt
if this study goes forward
would your department welcome the
opportunity to work with them
absolutely the division would be
providing i would imagine provide much
of the information required for the
committee
any other questions representative
fellows
so if you've been working on this for a
while can you
i mean i
understand that
the vacancy rate in terms of eight well
some of them are obviously hr positions
i i understand that but i think the
even if you were fully staffed it would
seem like a slow operation have you
identified any
changes other than
training that
might help with the situation that might
make it faster
one of the proposals the department put
forward recently for use of some of the
recovery funds from the federal monies
is actually to
hire three dedicated hiring managers who
will sit in the division of personnel
who will be focused exclusively on
hiring for critical need positions
positions where we actually have higher
than the average vacancy rate we have
vacancy rates up in 20 and 30 percent in
some areas of our state government
and having dedicated hiring managers is
one of the solutions we're going to be
exploring exploring
to see if
because right now most of our hiring
managers in the state are also managers
of programs and operations
they're not fully dedicated to hiring
and so in addition to hiring trying to
hire and fill positions they're trying
to manage their programs and their
operations at the same time
and so
thank you are there other questions from
the committee
okay yes representative grota
thank you madam chair i just want to
clarify what you just said so you're
saying that we don't we don't have
any hiring managers that are 100
dedicated to hiring
they're just they have other functions
of other job requirements as well
most of our hiring managers across the
state have other job functions
responsibilities there are some human
resource staff in some of the larger
agencies who are dedicated to supporting
recruitment but that is not the normal
situation
thank you
representative fellow
so maybe i'm misunderstanding it almost
sounds like you're saying
that the the person who is hiring
somebody that they are going to
supervise
is holding up the process because
they're too busy
sometimes that is the case they because
it falls to them the prior process in
the state is that application a job is
posted
applicants apply
jobs are posted internally for five days
we have to review our internal
applicants before we can
open our job to an external external
candidates
the hr
individuals will review those applicants
and determine who certifies for the job
those applicants are then passed on to
the hiring manager for review the hiring
manager then must review the applicants
and determine if they wish to interview
any of those applicants proceed to
schedule
interviews and proceed through that
process
that's the normal process that we
currently follow
thank you very much for that information
and i am glad to hear that you will be
supporting the study committee if it is
created
of course obviously
your knowledge is going to be necessary
thank you very much any other uh
does anyone else wish to testify on
house bill 1510
uh
could you give us a ping card for your
with your data on it
thank you
all right
so
anyone else wish to testify on house
bill 1510
all right seeing none thank you i'm
going to close the hearing on 15 10.
madam chair yes i have just a few
moments i have a get well card for our
colleague representative schmidt which i
will circulate thank you
thank you we're actually
starting the hearing on house bill
i don't have any cards from anybody so i
assume nobody wants to testify for it
that happens not to be the case thank
you
um represented
representative turcotte could you
introduce us
introduce the bill and tell us about it
well good afternoon everybody uh
representative glenn turcotte i
represent stratford county district four
i sit on the labor committee finance
committee special committee on
redistricting and senior advisor in the
house majority office i hadn't come to
introduce it but i will put it in on
behalf
of representative huff who is the prime
sponsor
today i am here
on behalf of the house majority office
to
give our support
of improved accountability in the
rulemaking process we are in favor of
reforming this process and the general
concept of the bill
but possibly we believe there are some
improvements or other change we would
like to be considered
rulemaking is our dele is our
delegation of legislative authority to
the executive this bill requires formal
explicit approvals for rules rather than
review by a committee
and assumed approval with the
legislative disapproval only on an
exception basis we've all seen that the
legislator no longer really has control
on many occasions of the rule-making
process and we know that the rules have
the same impact on invid individ
individuals and businesses as laws do
on a global basis the intent is to
restore the legislative authority on
policy procedure matters affecting the
people of new hampshire
agencies are occasionally writing rules
that clearly go beyond the scope and
intent of the legislator writing the
bill and the legislative body passing it
overall we believe it's time to amend
rsa 541a to ensure that unelected
government employees are not
policymakers and no longer have the
ability to effectively create law
through rules
some ideas the house majority office
would like to see discussed and
considered
jalcar should be empowered with the
authority of no means no meaning that
rules shall not move forward at the
outset prior to the express affirmative
vote
of the committee
we believe providing gel car with the
authority to compel responsive uh
responses from agencies in timely manner
um this is another item suggested by uh
members of the house majority office
we'd also like to see improving
public and business input on
proposed rulemaking before the vote
and we'd also like to the possibility of
having the policy committee chairs vice
chair sponsor specifically involved with
the proposed rule
prior to the vote by jalcar
finally
having just come from the speaker's
office
like i said i'm here representing the
house majority office but
the other side of house leadership
we believe that it would be
to the benefit if a subcommittee
could be formed
on this bill so the bill itself could be
utilized as a vehicle for other needed
improvements that other people
in leadership have uh
relayed to me
uh with that
i'm not here to take questions this is
not my
wheelhouse
if it's a simple question i guess i
could take it other than that
i'll conclude my testimony
thank you representative trick out
representative blackis has a question
hope it's simple enough yeah i think it
is um if you could just email a copy of
what you read there to the committee
appreciate it i will be happy to do that
thank you
other questions
representative schuett
thank you madam chair
one of the issues that you
particularly raised or the majority
office raised was the amount of time
that it takes for rules to come into
effect and i agree that in some
instances it is quite lengthy
i'm serving on gel car myself
however
some of these things that you're talking
about instituting seems like it could
even possibly lengthen the amount of
time that it would take
once again this is not my
wheelhouse representative schutt these
were talking points that we came up with
in the house majority office there are
other vindials
in-house leadership much more
well-versed in this than i am i
apologize
other questions
seeing none thank you representative
chercott thank you
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on house bill 1395
all right seeing none
i think this will go to the
scitec subcommittee and rules
and
we will
i will close the public hearing on house
bill 1395.
that concludes our planned business for
the day
does someone have a motion on house bill
1274 the study of solid waste
i guess nobody thinks it's easy enough
all right thank you all
oh
please please don't leave before you can
sign peter's card yes peter is out of
the hospital thank goodness but he well
he's in rehab but we won't see him for a
bit i am right
okay
see you all on tomorrow
you